[Applause]
i'm starting to dislike my girl she
didn't even do nothing
this is like when she's literally
building up a story of my girl doing
that and she even do it and i don't like
her now this is how girls feel when they
wake up from a dream and they found out
that you cheated oh [ __ ] this is what
you're doing that's what i feel like
i'm not even going to watch the bachelor
with her tonight bro i was supposed to
go and watch the bachelor
i'm watching love on the spectrum
instead of tell you something
yeah don't punish yourself don't beat
yourself up i mean
i gotta tell you bachelor don't take
that away you got this prehistoric [ __ ]
trying to get married on this what is
she doing she's cheating on all these
guys
mature mentally of course you are you're
38. that's how you got 39 bro
tick-tock tick-tock let me say some
time's up she got a whole omelette with
them
eggs down there let's be honest
she said they said kobe was put on the
back what i just said
was that alone i just gave you papa pp
no but kobe postponed the bachelor what
two months or some [ __ ] like that
she don't got it no this is valuable
time what you doing yeah i know
is she trying to run a ppp scandal on
the bachelor
really y'all didn't know about what's
going on the bachelor season
allegedly she got a relationship with
one of the dudes already
the dude's on the show and they're like
yo we're just going to work it out
and i'm going to choose you this guy in
my life well i can corroborate the story
because i watched the whole episode
yeah son it's pretty good dude
crazy what's his name dale bro yeah
dale's a pretty [ __ ] dale yeah i
don't blame her dale could do better
honestly i was saying that the whole
time and then i started to look at this
girl
she kind of as trump would say
yo trump got to stop being so likable
bro sad it's a problem
yo it's a problem tell me this isn't
likeable his first security briefing
this just came out
his first security briefing he's sitting
down he's in like mar-a-lago like his
hotel or whatever like that
he's sitting with the security advisors
and they're giving him all the secrets
yeah right it's a to get in you have to
have a code it's like a secret code
meeting
you can't get to the meeting it's just
the [ __ ] who know everything
know who we gotta kill
know who we already killed know what
happened to jfk know about ufos all that
okay know exactly where he is in cuba
yeah alive
okay he's in the meeting in the middle
of the meeting he stops it
he waves a waiter in to the security
briefing meeting
and goes guys we've got amazing
milkshakes okay the most amazing
milkshakes you've ever had do you guys
want a malt does anybody want a malt do
you guys want them all
anybody want i'm gonna have a milkshake
orders a [ __ ]
milkshake in the middle of the security
meeting
i tell you for sure i would have been
looking around if i'm security like i
could kind of go for i want a milkshake
i'm a little i get thirsty when i do
this briefing nobody ever asks me
you know how many times i've done this
breathing i never had a mole who
wouldn't love a malt
i'm saying you're laughing now because
you know a little part of you is in that
meeting like all right the country's
gone but it's going away in a fun way
i'll be like yo can i get the extra can
i get the extra that you don't put in
the game
bro bring that 10. bring that 10.
i hate it when they try to keep the 10.
don't do that
were you with me were you with me when i
called him out well you be doing that
on the regular on the regular they try
to bring me the [ __ ] milkshake
and then not bring the tin right
i go hey bro they got the tin part
what's the tin yeah okay so they have a
metal
mixing thing that goes into the
milkshake blender okay and the reason
it's metal is because that milkshake
blender is made out of metal as well you
could cut some [ __ ] up you could break
glass
okay so you make the milkshake and then
you pour it into the glass and then you
bring the glass to the people at the
table
sometimes you make too much milkshake
sometimes all the time yes oh so there's
extra milkshakes extra milkshake this
[ __ ] gonna say to me
uh no no that's how much was there i go
what about the 10 is it the left and the
10. she goes no that's all there was
i go with this [ __ ] i go i go are you
telling me
you made the perfect is that you saying
that you
eyeballed it and you made the perfect
amount of milkshake
what'd she say to me yes bro yes
yes she stuck to her guns i gotta
believe that i knew it
i'm gonna be able to do some [ __ ] like a
white woman she didn't give you the
milkshake she ain't giving me the rest
of the milk
god bless her though god bless her [ __ ]
god bless her you ever been to a jamba
juice though they'd be getting that [ __ ]
perfect though
nah there's always extra at the juice
bruh there's extra that should be
perfect they pour you in there look at
the blender
they're not giving you what you deserve
real talk god damn yeah but i don't want
no more jamba juice
why do i i don't know man jamba juice i
don't trust what
i just don't think it's good for you i
think it's all sugar you're talking
about milkshakes right now the [ __ ] you
got
you're getting the extra milkshake hey
we're going to them for different
reasons bro you know what i said
i used to go to jamba just think it was
a protein shake i was like man this
tastes miraculous that's all you
that's what i mean i know you're like i
didn't know that dumb lady that was
giving her kids nutella every day
and then sue nutella because she was
like i thought it was healthy
i did think it was healthy marketing was
healthier but it had the nuts on it
it had the nuts on it i thought it was
just peanut butter i would eat that [ __ ]
with a spoon
i was literally spooning it you want can
i be honest with y'all i would eat with
my fingers bro
i would go like that i'd scoop it out
with my fingers
that's pre-corona that's pre-caramel did
you ever think like mcdonald's was
healthy
no they never marketed as such yeah that
but nutella it's chocolate
no no it's not marketed as such
yourself if you didn't choose chicken
sandwich to be a little healthy yeah
yourself that is a fact because chicken
what could be bad in that it's just
chicken in the bread
and yo have you ever done this move you
have something unhealthy
like a burger or a chicken sandwich and
then you go let me get lettuce tomato on
it
and then you think it automatically
makes it absolutely it don't make it
healthier no i don't know
but in my mind it's like it's sadly it's
chocolate
it's nutrition it's salad
i turn into salad and the bread is
croutons i just added vitamins
there was a time where old people were
valuable to us
like that's why old people just want to
die from corona now because of y'all
y'all never ask him any [ __ ] what
you've never bought something like from
mcdonald's and you wanted to get water
to make you feel more healthy oh no i do
taylor what the [ __ ] did you just say
if that water makes it more healthy
i do i understand as opposed to soda or
juice
yes as opposed to soda i thought you
thought like we were talking about what
you did to the actual burger to make it
healthier
she extrapolated it i think i'm with you
on this i'm gonna clear no because
that's because i know the mcdonald's is
unhealthy so i get the water
this is a very important point that we
got to make and i didn't realize why old
people want to die so bad from corona
it's because your generation doesn't
make them feel valuable our generation
didn't have any information we weren't
going to encyclopedia britannica that
[ __ ] we will put up
all the racism because they're the only
ones who knew things they knew things
they knew that we go ask them questions
what was the war like
they would tell you it would be racist
but it'd be very entertaining
no but could their stories compare you
ask
real quick hey we're studying for world
war ii test can you tell us what
happened your grandpa come
lumbering in real quick one foot missing
because of that asian dude's grandpa
took that [ __ ] off
souvenirs not a rabbit foot why do they
like
feet so much that's a great point what
is it about the feed asians
binding them grabbing them
painting the toenails why do you guys
like to think so much
what's happening asians what do you know
that i know too ninjas are always
wearing sandals and [ __ ]
oh my god easy access to the feed yeah
it's an open toe culture
it's an open soul culture they always be
analyzing feet all day they can't help
it and you know what i'm kind of with
them i like it
i like a foot too i like the good feet
out there bad ones can
stay locked up put yourself in that
[ __ ] have you ever seen a bound
foot
nah you never seen a bound foot i don't
stop saying it like
yo let me tell you something a nice
bounce foot
that [ __ ] wrapped how does that look
it's wrapped up like creed's hands or
what
it's honestly it's not it goes like this
say that's your foot
these toes come under oh yeah yeah they
miss yelling at that makes a nice little
lollipop
turn that foot into a lollipop
okay that's a little dumpling get up
that little
get up that soup dumpling right there
you got a nice little
foot i'm trying to see you know look at
that
that's a nice that's a kitkat break you
off one
break you off one bro look how delicious
them little feets are
what taylor don't judge other cultures i
should look like cauliflower
yes i can't do it yo nah
that's beautiful you don't want to talk
about you don't like second toe longer
guaranteed